we never finished this show we never
finished this yesterday mike this guy's
my favorite
we got to finish this for those this guy
is my favorite
for for those who don't know the the
first part of this video is up on the
clip channel youtube.com
rotc media search for rotc clips it's
the alpha show
and uh we started this video yesterday
it got too late so i want to get into it
early so we could finish it
it's how to make girls horny instantly
so
we left off with start talking flirty
with her which was by the way
there's so many things wrong with this
guy like
first of all you know i've said before i
hate
programs i hate i hate anything that
treats human interaction like a game
or because it's it's you're training
people how to be psychopaths
you're not supposed to like when you sit
down to something
and introduce yourself to somebody right
whether it's a guy girl whether it's
sexual or otherwise
there's no there shouldn't be this
psycho game that you're playing it
should just be like a
you're interacting with somebody you're
talking to them whatever
and it's like these people turn it into
like a point system
like they're checking off things on a
bowling squirt card and you're like
that's a sick way to look at talking to
people you're just
supposed to talk to people and like if
you know social cues and how to pick up
on stuff you're talking to a chick
if you know how to read this situation
you'll know within the first 15 minutes
whether or not
you got a shot or not i'm not saying
they're going to take in a bathroom and
blow you right away but
you know in the first 15 minutes like
okay i could work this a little bit i
could probably get this chick to
hang out sometime but this guy
everything's like a make sure you do
step when they when they follow these
things
these programs they always do everything
so literally that they end up terrifying
these women too
they're always like make eye contact so
the guys will just go off to women and
not even blink
and [ __ ] like that so like to touch her
face do you picture a guy going down
this checklist and being like
okay so to touch your finger just touch
your finger apart
what are you doing spill her drink
you're all [ __ ] knocking [ __ ] over i
had to touch your finger it was number
three on the list
list and then the girl's like list what
list
i'm supposed to be making you horny
right away what
sir sit down and buckle up we're about
to land
of the sexy time both of you have shared
number four
touch her fingers play it safe and slow
if she feels
awkward or uncomfortable it's the end of
the road for your sexual
entrepreneur find an excuse to touch her
fingers either by brushing her poem with
yours
or by giving her something to hold
compliment her about her
fingers absolutely ridiculous theory if
you really want to [ __ ] gage
if you really want to gauge whether or
not a chick is willing to [ __ ] you or
not
and by the way this is not something i'd
recommend you do
especially if you just sat down next to
some girl at a starbucks but
if you've been talking to a chick for a
while right you really want to know if
the [ __ ] you're not
touch their face you will i'm if you
want the
quickest answer right then and there if
a girl's gonna [ __ ] you or not you don't
want to waste three more dates taking
her out
find a way to touch your face if they
don't recoil at all if they actually are
like completely just either indifferent
or warm to the idea you're touching
their face
you're in you're done my buddy came up
with that theory years ago and i was
like that's insane
but it has the highest rate of success
it's like the the piss test strips it's
like just a litmus test if they let you
touch your face
you're in fingers not so much i walk up
and i randomly touch girls faces all the
time they seem to
do it randomly yeah randomly i'm just
saying when they're sleeping
that's breaking and entering and
probably
that's sounds kind of nice
that's probably i think that's why
they're recoiling
or how smooth it is she'd know your
nothing games by now but as long as you
keep the pace slow
and enjoyable she'll like your sensual
touches another good way is to pretend
like you read poems it will work even if
she knows you have no idea
about it just a quick pro tip too if you
read palms oh he meant palms
yeah not psalms he said poems no you
should sit down and read psalms to women
they love them they're pretty sexy some
of the songs are sexy
but by the way go back to the face
touching thing best way to do it
is do the eyelash move just tell them
and don't don't even do the like
oh milady you had an eyelash like you
got to be kind of a dick about it you
got to be like fool and then if they
don't do anything about the face thing
be like oh sorry you had an eyelash was
bothering the [ __ ] out of me
say it that way with her and say
something naughty when you see her palms
if that doesn't you will have six kills
in a nice car i will be your [ __ ] friend
in the near future
fork touch her fingers and compliments i
i it's
almost it's almost worth strapping a
girl gopro on
i'm telling you try it i would love to
do you should do it
that would be one weekend just go out to
tampa
did you imagine i do that right and like
99 girls reject me but just
one really hot 25 year old's like okay
like yeah but you got to keep the gopro
on through everything
i know frank castle's guy yes like david
bonds
a ring or her bracelet or even her
earrings
just make sure you warm her up to your
touches number five
whisper into her ears this is especially
good these are
all like tropes yeah right these are all
tropes none of this works
this is all things that they read in
these books
and by the way again like i said
yesterday it's like this is the same
thing that academia
is based on like a bunch of people that
have never done
anything in practice they're all a bunch
of people that read books
and then they teach the next generation
based on the books they read what the
things are but they don't have
any they have no real world experience
to compare it to this guy
read all these little tips and he's
sharing these tips with a bunch of even
more hopeless retards
but he's never gone out and done any of
this and had it work
there are other people around both of
you who are too preoccupied with
something else
movie theaters bus journeys the back
seat of a car with friends when another
guy is driving or if both of you are at
home watching a movie are perfect times
to include the whispering egg don't
if both of you were if she's already at
your house to watch a movie
you don't need to do any of this yeah if
she's already
in your home it's on you're good like
at this point you don't need any tricks
if the woman is already in your house
she's going willing to have sex with you
yeah and if they don't then you
either said you did something in the
course of them being there
or your house is gross something
something happened
from the time they decided to go there
to the time they decided
you know my signature move i do the
bronx tale i lock the door go now you
just can't leave
okay well that's also very i don't think
so
i don't think probably shouldn't lock
the door and then announce it that's
usually and i sit with one arm around
her and the other arm with a baseball
bat
what i like to do my move is i like to
have like seven locks on my door
that's a good idea really difficult
and then one one of them one of them is
just the old-school like
piece of plywood like the big chunk of
wood
that you put in the two slots like in
like an
old-timey medieval gate
don't be funny while whispering into her
ear if she laughs it is
it completely kills the moose whispers
things like
i am going to kill you
also the other the other funny pro move
is to have a like a camera but a fake
one like a dummy camera in the bathroom
that's good that'd be freaked out and
then they walk out be like i saw you
poop
i saw you make a pool now i will touch
your finger
somebody had corn the other day
[Laughter]
so when they freak out you know no it's
not a real cameras
it's fake i just like to i like to do
that to get the blood pump you see you
were freaked out for a second
they're just in a terrible mood after
that they're like
adrenaline's pumping they're frantically
trying to call an uber to leave
here like you are whispering something
and compliment her again
and what did he just write why did he
just
and he's saying i like your ass which
again how do you phrase that so poorly
wait let's get some of the ladies let's
see if it works hey ladies
i like your ass are you wet that
honestly doesn't even work
while you're [ __ ] a girl in the ass
okay you're like yeah
obviously you do ah yes i like your ass
like okay
what this if you told me this was parody
i would have been like this is genius
that's brilliant
if you said to me like oh you know
somebody did this to make fun of all the
pickup guys i'd go oh this is brilliant
then i didn't know
say you just had to compliment her about
the same thing again
just be a [ __ ] the guy you know what
i mean
no no i don't know what first off you're
barely speaking english second of all
you don't know what you mean
exactly you what are you saying be a man
what am i supposed to hit her in the
head like a caveman and drag her into my
room
i can already tell you 99 of you people
that watch this sort of thing
are never gonna get laid and i'll tell
you why because
you don't you lack the one thing that
you need
to get laid and that is not giving a
[ __ ]
whether or not you get laid that's the
only thing that works
so a chick in the chat mona lisa says
you look how i wish my mom looked always
works on me
you look how i wish my mom looked if you
want to get straight to the point
whisper into her ear and ask her if
she'd like to hang out with you later
whispering something
inmate like a date request with some
heavy breathing
in the background will make the hair of
the back of her neck and hands
hey you wanna go on a date dude even now
like
even now probably like when i go out and
stuff when we like run into old people
or whatever we're hanging out like in
tampa like
even now there's a pretty good
percentage of girls that probably want
to [ __ ] me just because
of how not interested i am it
really does work more than any of these
programs will ever work
is hey you know we're uh we got this art
show on thursday did you want to go with
us it's going to be like
remember so and so and so and so we're
all going to go you and i could drive in
together and it's so like
nowadays i'm just more like yeah i don't
know
i don't know probably not no you know
and then that's literally works more
because then they're like
why so we could go in together i'll even
drive you know because i know you want
to have some drinks or whatever
yeah like i said i just don't want to
commit because i'll probably wake up and
not want to even leave my apartment and
that make i'm telling you
that works more than i like your fingers
i like to i like your ass wet
and make sure your lips graze her ears
so she can feel
a hint of a teasing kiss on her ear okay
here comes
uh one of my examples hey babe
would you like to dance
would you what are you a vampire
tell her compliments because she never
hears them and she will totally
take to them very well i want to suck
your blood huh what is this guy from
transylvania
hey girl do you want to dance
you're way more likely to get laid
telling a girl
so like those earrings and those shoes
was that a deliberate choice
oh my god this is [ __ ] amazing
would you like me to come to your house
and then
do the tralala okay
what's the trello i don't know but he's
slowly morphing into horse the longer
this video goes on
what's happening hello i would like to
touch your ear
hey just something like that you know
not the same as i said right now but
you know you know something good yeah
maybe something that's not going to
scare out of the house
go along with the lines just say
something with that
heavy voice number six reach out from
across her
to make any of these moves delicious
what do you mean what does that mean
it's bad english
okay in the air if you don't feel it
don't try this move
and when you feel the sexual chemistry
thicken the problem is anyone buying
these things
is not going to be able to properly read
sexual tension
they're just going to that's what i'm
saying right they do something they just
follow
so is there sexual tension why are you
crying
also the kind of girls i [ __ ] the
kind of girls i date would never put up
with
this this move depicting picking them up
i know any girl i've ever dated would be
like what am i your [ __ ] six-year-old
daughter what are we at the park
put me the [ __ ] down what is wrong with
you and in the air
don't worry she'll feel it too and even
got aroused by it
now that you've been touching her and
whispering into her ear it's time to
take you to the next level find an
excuse to reach out
to something from across her energy i'm
sorry what does that mean
but this again well reach out
i guess to touch her but the thing is
like
coming coming with the the
the whole i need to have an excuse to
touch you thing
it's like the excuse should just be like
i felt like touching you
anything short of that is disingenuous
they're gonna pick up on that
this is this is literally the
move and it's like that's corny and
they're gonna go you're really just
trying to find it
like just pro tip don't do it to
strangers
at theaters they get very angry yeah
well yeah that would be probably
just you'll get off me
especially don't do it to their kids no
they really don't they'll get mad
but like literally if you're sitting
next to a girl and you wanted to lay on
you you do this
you just look at them and go like this
you give them the whole
mirror that's it that's all you do it's
not like oh
i am so tired i will stretch but my arm
will just accidentally land on your
booby
it's none of that we're gonna work reach
your hand out to pick something up make
sure your shoulder
or arm excuse me i'm reaching for my
knife
that works at this point is where you
will reach for your binding tools and
things like that
raises her breast or some other
strategic body parts
this is not a word you want to graze her
breasts so grope her
that's groping by those guys that's
groping
innocent and don't jerk back or look
awkward make it seem natural
like you are a clean bone none of this
seems natural though
all of this if you're the moment that
lifts her involved it's not a natural
thing anymore
doing nothing wrong if her breasts are
out of reach
move your hands across her back or over
her thight
or just about any place that you
wouldn't touch in other casual curls
this one's easy right you hang out or
whatever and then you go uh
hey you want to go in the room and if
they're like i don't know if i'm ready
for that be like
all right that's fine look i i gotta go
to bed so
bye that's it you just saved yourself
all this reading
homework two hours of strategizing
if they come back to your house watch
about 20 minutes of something and then
go you wanna go in the room
if they go no go all right and get out
i'm going to bed
number seven read her reputation if she
starts speaking slowly or moves closer
to you chances are she's horny as you
are right somebody just said
still want to move to eastern europe
yeah if the guys are like this
i'll be a f are you kidding me i'll be
the biggest chad in the world
out there compared to this [ __ ] carey
goes
show her photos of a pet you've killed
what
been following these tips to the t you
definitely have an erection already just
play along and repeat the flirting
teasing touching and reaching out to the
body parts now and then as long as both
of you are enjoying it
raise your hands against her breasts or
watch her t-shirt
and if you find anything this is
starting to sound very
this is taking a distinctly return
top you've just worked your magic and
made what magic
i think you'd you'd have an easier time
getting [ __ ] doing
actual magic i just made you i just made
the consent disappear
just pulling a top hat out and tapping
what is he doing pulling scarves out of
her [ __ ]
just keeps going my friend
good job my friend hell yeah number
eight
the final step ask her out now all this
whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa you've already
grabbed your breath
multiple times at your house i'm sorry
but i'm just what's happening what's
what is this
she got in your house you groped her
breasts you still you [ __ ]
you flicked her bean your [ __ ] now you
this is this out of order you've tricked
the mail woman into coming into your
house
and groped your breasts pulled your dick
at it and you're like would you like to
go on the dates sometimes
what's going on here i think you're
getting this all wrong sir
[Laughter]
now that you have her you are ready to
go on a date
what
[Laughter]
this is so stupid one shouldn't go to
waste should it tease her and play with
her
now you can have sex with your cartoon
gta woman
[Music]
wasted results may vary to love it all
the more or if you want to do something
more about it
go close to her ear and ask her if she'd
like to come over to your place now
don't be a little
[ __ ] and just do it my man and girls if
you've been watching this video let us
know
uh in the comments if that is true will
would that make it horrible comment down
below if that it's true
if they if you're dropping breaths yes
i did number six and it got me in the
principal's office
be very subtle you smell nice
this man is actually funny though mom
i'm on the side
mom i'm on that side of youtube again
uh i i'm the o i'm the only one that
gets crazy when someone whispers to
into my ear uh
what if the first tip makes the girl
disturbed i am a girl i should know
[Music]
he's got to get laid too i guess 1.7
million views
yeah but this is not 30 000 subs people
are sharing these videos as a joke so
make fun of them
of course um that is it you are in my
man
well what was that called the alpha what
i don't know
the alpha show alpha show they're gonna
watch more of those videos
the alpha show it's actually really good
stuff